now joining us with a deeper look at all
this is silac kapoor he's national
political reporter for Bloomberg News
good morning good morning well if the
lawmakers in Washington are confused by
the president what are we supposed to
make of the possibility of gun reform
here
well it's certainly it's certainly
baffling a lot of members of Congress
Democrats and Republicans but as the
president kind of went out there and
took a position for gun control against
the politics within his party but I
think what most people are thinking is
state is you know Republicans at least
stay in a holding pattern right now
don't go against the politics got the
president of mercurial he's shifted
before you don't know if as Jeff Flake
put it to me it's gonna be the Tuesday
Trump or the Thursday Trump the
president has an extraordinary ability
to influence his party if he's
consistent and methodical on this given
his credibility with the party base but
so far on immigration he moved away from
that stance after showing an intent to
compromise at first and he's beginning
to do the same on guns well in terms of
both immigration and gun safety reform
there have been a number of high profile
meetings and statements and all the rest
but legislatively do you expect anything
to be done this year unlikely I think
there are no two issues that Republican
leaders are more eager to avoid than gun
control and immigration liberalisation
as congressional primaries are coming up
and many of them are facing an
electorate that does not want to go
there with these two issues so I think
most likely we're looking at a Congress
that just tries to keep the lights on
physically no government shutdowns no
catastrophic debt default and let the
voters decide the rest of November
meanwhile there was a major personnel
changes at the White House this week and
some potential personnel changes as well
let's talk about hope Hicks first very
close to the president how does this
affect the president do you think it's a
momentous change because she is one of
the few people probably the only person
who's still in the White House close to
the president in his inner circle who's
been with him before he was in politics
when he was in the private sector here
in New York all throughout the campaign
the transition team the inauguration and
she rose to become communications
director in the White House practically
by default because everyone else kept
getting pushed out or you know getting
fired or ended up leaving for one reason
or another so these are big these are
big shoes to fill the important thing
about her I would say is that unlike
most people in the Trump orbit she's
kind of floated above the fray in you
know a circle that's been defined by
leaking and backstabbing and you know
all sorts of nasty chaos yeah
speaking of the inner circle those in
and those out there's been a dramatic
conflict publicly between the president
and his attorney general Jeff Sessions
what do you make of that Sahil this is
the first time we've actually seen Jeff
Sessions pushback on a president that's
absolutely right and I think I think you
know Jeff sessions are standing up for
himself after a barrage of Twitter
attacks from the president that's gone
on you know throughout the year it's
highly unusual to see this is not a
normal thing to see the president
publicly feuding with members of his own
cabinet what about the president's
son-in-law Jared Kushner who whose
security clearance top secret clearance
he lost it this week and at the same
time there are questions about his
business relationships he's in there
rumors of him fighting with mr. Kelley
as well is he at risk these are
certainly dark days I think for the
presidential son-in-law it's gonna it's
been a rough week he's lost his top
secret clearance he's in the crosshairs
of special counsel Bob Muller and the
Russia investigation he's millions of
dollars of debt we've learned that
governments foreign governments are
looking at ways to potentially
manipulate him as a result of his
complex business dealings with his
family and you know his status I think
is probably more tenuous than it's been
but again family members have a special
place in the president's aura but I
suspect if he wants to stick around
you'll find a way
but this chaos is having practical
implications in terms of u.s. foreign
policy in terms of u.s. position on
issues like trade the president's
announced tariffs on the steel alone on
an aluminum industry came as a shock to
most of his own advisers including Gary
Cohen what can we learn from this sahil
well so a few things it's it was
certainly abrupt the way it came about
right no internal government review no
diplomatic strategy no communication
strategy to sell this and explain it but
nobody should be surprised that he did
it
trade protectionism in closed borders or
perhaps the one consistency of Donald
Trump's worldview since well before he
was in politics but his own advisers did
not believe he was there on this issue
yet up until this week is that right and
that's why we should we should take from
this that President Trump only really
listens to himself on the issue of trade
you're absolutely right that there's a
division in the White House and most
members of his own party the leadership
and in Congress are not in favor of this
the most interesting thing here is that
there's a threat of retaliation from the
EU two of the companies that they're
threatening to go after Harley Davidson
and
Kentucky Bourbon headquartered in the
home states of House Speaker Paul Ryan
and Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell that's not a coincidence
some very shrewd EU decision-making a
Regents I held Kippur will be talking
more about those tariffs and the global
implications coming up in the next hour
thank you for your time Sahel thank you